the jurgen experience
basically long story short
phd student drop out of the phd go to
work at wall street wall street blows up
i come back to tech right or back to
tech i never worked in tech but i gone
to school in berkeley and i'd seen kind
of the first tech bubble so i was kind
of vaguely aware of it
joined tech
join ad tech do my own startup
tiny little company not a big success
get sold to twitter i end up at facebook
a year before the ipo
as one of the early members of the ads
team so
if you go like browse for [ __ ] on the
internet and you see that same pair of
shoes inside your instagram feed or
whatever
i created the very first versions
initial not what they're now versions of
that so a lot of the i was the first
like product manager for ads targeting
so like how
user data gets turned into a successful
ads campaign is what i was responsible
for in a very formative period in the
company's history
and so
i was there again not that terribly long
but it was a lot happened the company
went grew in size enormously and figured
out how to make money like i didn't know
how to [ __ ] make money the ads the
ads as it remembers used to suck and now
everyone's like ads are either creepy or
crappy there's no in between so i went
from crappy to creepy um
it was a big team a lot of people did
stuff to make that happen so the book is
about that like how do you start a
company how do you raise money the inner
workings of silicon valley i went
through this famous incubator thing
called y combinator when you say crappy
to creepy do you mean invasive yeah yeah
in the sense of like oh this is like
totally relevant to like oh i was
literally just searching for this thing
and here's an ad for it let me ask you
about this because we've talked about
this multiple times in the podcast
sometimes you're having a conversation
oh god the microphone thing is that real
no it's not real no no i mean
i don't believe them see no no you were
just talking about something the other
day i haven't searched for it at all
okay and i got an ad for it it was
something me and you were talking about
what was it
if i remember right i couldn't remember
but it was something we talked about
after the show
six hours later i'm getting an ad for it
here's what i'd bet on one of you two
either searched or went to some website
not only one of us what so if i do he
gets an app yeah that potentially yeah
how
uh the term of art is called lookalike
audiences what that means is so
some retailer knows that you dump a
bunch of money at whatever rei cabela's
pick your favorite retailer whatever
you two are buds and you interact a lot
on whatever social media platform if i'm
cabela's say just decided example i'm
like okay i know this guy is worth
whatever two thousand dollars a year get
me more people like him and companies
like facebook or other companies can say
ah well guess what he talks to this dude
a lot who by the way whose profile kind
of looks like yours and so you'll get
targeted for something that you did
yeah i get that but we have very
different online things you know i look
sneakers and stuff he's looking at
hunting and whatnot the thing that came
up i wish i could i normally take a
screenshot when these things happen
because i'll share it with the person
yeah like look what just popped up on my
phone
this was outside of that yeah this is
one of those things i go all right
we need to talk about this
but again i know there's uh okay so let
me defenses to it but this was let me
address the question it's funny there
was a there's a planet money show about
this in which they talked to various
people who had this experience trying to
figure out how it actually happened i
was i was a guest on it but let me
address the problem so
imagine imagine i mean let's say let's
say mark zuckerberg is listening to your
conversations and gets like a live
stream of your phone all the time
what fraction of the time do you think
you're actually mentioning something
commercially interesting that would be
worth like targeting against like how
often do you say hey i'm flying to
boston next week and i need a flight in
a hotel on a taxi and you say it in some
structured way that would be easy it
it's pretty rare right and the amount of
i mean think about the amount of data
you'd have to you'd be on a constant
phone call basically to zuck it would
eat up your network like crazy and then
the fraction of the times versus you
just like going to [ __ ] kayak and
like entering boston and using that data
and so
i'm not saying it's technically
impossible and in some future world who
knows
but it would be difficult and even if
you managed to do it there isn't one of
the things
one of the chapters in my book i i
understand you're listening to have a
chapter called the narcissism of privacy
which comes off maybe more snarky than i
mean but
privacy is a right and people have a
right to it obviously but i think one of
the sort of misleading things when you
think about companies like facebook is
that like facebook wants to know the
thing that you least want them to know
which is like your personal conversation
with your loved one or whatever when it
comes to commercial data that actually
helps target ads there's very little
very little of what you do or things
that you wouldn't think of are what they
want not necessarily what you would like
what you would
not want facebook to know right but what
concerns people is the idea that your
microphone is picking up keywords that
they have accounts with so whether it's
uh
cell phones
tires whatever it is then you see an ad
for it it would be more possible than
like the smart speaker systems you have
at home for example right that that
wouldn't be so hard to
and so how would they target you for an
ad with that
well again if you said something well
structured that would be easy to tease
out and if that's connected to the same
account that's connected to your gmail
or your google search or amazon yeah or
amazon then they would show you the ads
yeah yeah so like a lot of what happens
that's actual targeting is like data
joining so like getting back to the
cabela's example like i understand
you're into hunting so maybe you shop at
the local cabela's or the bass pro shop
um
they'll have your phone number and email
for all the [ __ ] you buy online and what
they want to do is like find you online
and sell you because it's the [ __ ]
deer hunting season sale or whatever and
they try to and so what they'll do is
they'll upload that list of emails to
facebook and say oh this is the this is
the deer hunting group and then they'll
show you ads based on your actual buying
history so that sort of thing absolutely
does happen yeah that makes sense what
is it like being in those
companies like whether it's facebook or
you know any any sort of tech company
for someone on the outside we we look at
it and we say like how are those [ __ ]
places run because it's like i've had a
good friend who was a big executive at
google and now she works at another
large tech company and the way she
described it to me she's like it is
utter madness
it's utter madness and the lunatics are
running the asylum to a certain extent
because
there's a lot of people the company that
she works for now
so a lot of people that are inside the
company that legitimately are mentally
ill and they consider themselves
activists and they have to placate them
because there's a certain percentage of
the population of the people that work
for the company and they're the loudest
and they oftentimes don't get work done
and when confronted they could they talk
about their activism right and like
she's like listen
you are here for you know x amount of
hours a day this is your [ __ ] job
you're not an activist right and don't
think that if you're complaining about
other things that this company does that
you doing that is a part of your job
because it is not
yeah i mean i think the companies are
somewhat to blame because they've done
the whole like bring the real self to
work thing right and again what is that
there's this philosophy among like the
hr there that like
and if you're being cynical about it
it's engineered to get the most
productivity out of you like the real
the real soft like if you work at some
of these companies basically again to
answer your question i think it depends
what stage of the company you join if
you're talking about big companies like
apple google facebook now um
it it's a campus it's a lifestyle they
do your laundry for you they feed you
there's like they do your laundry they
can't yeah yeah there's like apple does
your laundry i'm not sure about apple
because we were never in office because
it was still under covered but facebook
had had laundry i'm sure google does
yeah whoa yeah it's it's weird it's you
join i mean
it's a strained analogy but it's kind of
like a cult and there's like a massive
amount of corporate culture like i
described this lot in chaos monkeys who
said that
who said that quote that every
successful startup is a cult i think was
keith or boy i think from founders fund
and he the thing is he's right he's
right like facebook was a cult and i
joined it and that was a happy member of
it it was very powerful everyone
sacrificed themselves for the sake of
the facebook empire and its emperor did
it change your own personal thinking
while you were there in the cult oh yeah
did you subscribe to school age oh yeah
i totally bled blue i still do do a
certain thing absolutely because again
it's a formative experience like some of
the most impactful professional work i
did was there like it or not making
taking facebook ads from like the shitty
stupid little ipad offer ads on the
right to like literally the thing you
just looked at or bought which i know
sounds cringy whatever
that changed everything i was one of
many to be clear it wasn't just me but
that changed everything about that
company and was super impactful inside
the industry like how much of an impact
did it have when apple came along and in
introduced these restrictions
yeah you're talking about att which is
like the ads transparency thing for
those who don't know if you've got an
iphone like you you download an app and
suddenly there's like this opt-in that
apple is showing you saying hey do you
want to share your data with these
people
that's hugely impactful what that does
is
so why does that matter so apple
controls this they create the hardware
and the software and all of it right
right at the end of the day seen from
apple's point of view facebook as
powerful as it seems
is just another app in the app store
right which was always zuck's fear which
is why he wanted to build a phone
apple can say look facebook you can't
you don't get to track users as well as
you use so you can't track joe rogan
down or like anonymously your device id
you can't do that anymore you only get a
certain level of granularity how much
tracking were they able to do that
before that well i mean an infinite
amount they would track you individually
i mean whether it's worth doing now it's
another matter but they would get the
individual device id from your phone and
so they would know who you are in terms
of that phone they think yeah well what
does that entail
like again you know you if if you go to
if you go to cabela's and buy a thing
then you go to some you're playing a
casual game and they show you an ad
you playing that game and you buying
that thing in cabela's can be
individually joined in a very precise
way and if you remove that and say oh
you can't track joe rogan's phone
you're tracking a hundred thousand
people out of throw then they bucketize
you they put you in a bucket that isn't
quite as precise as before and what that
translates into is fewer clicks fewer
sales like the effective amount of money
that either the advertiser makes or the
publisher that's showing the ad mix goes
down
now is this
for the end user for the person who has
the phone
is it beneficial that they've
instituted these policies good question
um
if you get a warm fuzzy feeling inside
knowing you're not being individually
tracked yes
but other than that
not particularly but it also doesn't
give up the access
to your data that's this very valuable
commodity for facebook
right um
so here's the tricky thing about data
right one of the one of the many
misconceptions that i try to address in
the book about how facebook works is
it's often not facebook data that's
being used to target you because if you
think about facebook right it's like
you're posting random photos you're
engaging with content but a lot of your
commercial activity like booking
airplane flights shopping for [ __ ]
doesn't happen on facebook facebook
doesn't know about that strictly
speaking so how how do they solve that
problem that like we got to show him
[ __ ] shoe ads and facebook doesn't
know [ __ ] about what shoes you like
right
so part of this is what i described in
the book and what i helped build in the
early stages
there's a way of joining you joe rogan
facebook you to cabela's you in some
relatively data safe way that that lets
cabela show you an ad for those shoes
facebook doesn't necessarily know all
the cabela's [ __ ] because cabela's
doesn't want to let facebook know that
[ __ ] because they don't trust facebook
and so a lot of the stuff that's going
on isn't like oh facebook knows
everything about you it's like no
facebook knows who you are on every
device because you tend to use facebook
everywhere maybe not you but other
people and so that means that they can
join you very well to all the other
commercial activity you do and you use
facebook a lot so they have lots of
opportunities to maybe show you an ad so
that's really facebook's strength but
getting back to your original question
how does apple [ __ ] that up well it
[ __ ] it up because it doesn't know who
you are on that device at the individual
granular level anymore and so it can't
talk to cabela's and say oh that guy who
will look for these weird things like
show them this ad that that can't happen
anymore is it in any way negative for
the person who's the end user good
question um because maybe you would want
to see those those ads because this is
something that you're actually
interested in purchasing i mean in the
happy case but let's face it i mean in
the happy case and if you're a person
who's
you know you
have full control over your urges you're
not a person who's just like
you know you don't you can't afford
something but you buy it anyway because
you're [ __ ] crazy and you saw the ad
and you can't help yourself because we
know that there are people like that out
there right so
in the best case scenario
is it better
i would think so
but isn't that like what you do as a
business
i i think the status quo is a lot better
than the like stupid punch the monkey
ads you used to remember those ads and
like display band you probably don't
remember them but like in yahoo.com back
in the day to be like a little moving
target and then like punch the monkey
like you can either see that [ __ ] or
you can actually see an ad that maybe
has a chance of being relevant in
instagram feed so yeah that you give
anything up to have those relative ads
no in fact i mean you gained things
right like a lot of services wouldn't
exist if they weren't paid for via ads
so like the reality is
if facebook's ads start sucking more i.e
the amount of money they make per ads
goes down they're just going to show you
more ads so do you think that android
phones handle it better
because android phones allow more of
those things in yeah it's a super wonky
question i wasn't expecting this
it's wonky yeah no no no it's good i
think i love talking about it but um
the model that google and apple have are
somewhat different um apple is a fully
you know vertically integrated thing
they create literally the chips and the
software you're looking at google's a
little bit different um you can buy
android phones made by all sorts of
manufacturers
their model in general tends to be a
little bit more open to third parties
and so there's a whole ads ecosystem in
google where
i could [ __ ] fill this wall or a
whiteboard with all the little boxes of
all the little companies that like get
together to show you a single ad and so
google is a little bit better about
being more open to the outside mind you
they still use monopoly power in various
ways like they're not saints um but
apple has a more closed note approach to
it and that's why they're building an ad
system because they want to make money
in ads but they're not going to go the
google route they're going to build
more than likely i mean not that i have
deep insight into it anymore
but more than likely they're going to
build it themselves because they have a
more closed vision of it that how they
think about data privacy here's another
thing we want to geek out
one direction apple's going that's kind
of interesting is that a lot of the data
for your iphone's going to live on
device like in other words for the past
20 plus years of internet we've had this
model where like you do [ __ ] on a phone
data goes into the cloud weird [ __ ]
happens and you get shown a page or an
experience a lot of that's changing
right like
probably most of what you do on a phone
is through an app it's not a browser
anymore it's like the code is running on
your on your phone you're producing data
on that phone like why shouldn't the
computation and all the [ __ ] that
happens happen on the phone these phones
are actually pretty powerful right um
and so
a lot of things are moving in that
direction for a bunch of reasons one of
the reasons actually is privacy and you
know apple and other companies have made
public statements about this was like oh
it's more private like what's the
ultimate opt out my data's on this phone
you know i do i take it i throw it to
the [ __ ] lake their data's gone right
while like opt-out and deletion when the
data's in the cloud and a bunch of third
parties have it you never really know
right right but if you keep the data on
the phone it is better in many ways